Daisie swayed back and forth in her
chair a thin stream of drool hanging
from the corner of her mouth she
appeared not to notice it and she
appeared not to have heard dr. Jenner's
question so he gently repeated it why do
you want to eat human flesh Daisy her
eyes seemed to meet his for a moment and
he drew in his breath free swore he'd
seen a spark there though of what he
couldn't be sure was it simply hunger or
the effects of the drug the nurses came
to inject every four hours or could it
have been something else perhaps nothing
as profound as intelligence no but maybe
a kind of rudimentary understanding at
least he didn't want to get too excited
it had only been a flash a second but he
couldn't help his palms moistening Daisy
can you hear me do you understand he was
leaning toward her now closer than he
should have really they're reanimated
were still dangerous
despite the medication and it never paid
to be careless around them but Daisy
seemed far more responsive than any of
the other patients he'd interviewed in
the clinic he realized that wasn't
saying much but in this case he'd take
what he could get she was swaying
endlessly like a snake looking for a
place to strike all of them did that and
he assumed it was simply a manifestation
of their condition filtered through the
pharmaceuticals they were forced to take
by law she still didn't speak none of
them did or at least they never had when
live humans were around but her strange
eyes were fixed on his again and this
time they didn't simply drift away but
held there seeming to focus sharply
behind their milky lenses
dr. Jenner felt his pulse beginning to
race you do understand me don't you
he said whispering as if the two of them
were sharing some delicious secret this
could change everything he sat there for
another hour firing questions at her and
still getting no answers but becoming
more and more certain that he was
getting through to her on some level
which was far more than he could say
about any of the others when he finally
left the clinic he called out a musical
goodbye to Vera at the nurse's station
any luck today doc she asked him yes
birra I think my luck is improving you
will call me immediately if any of them
say a single word won't you you know I
will have a good one indeed
good day Vera
dr. Jenner left a clinic not noticing
the way Vera smiled indulgently and
shook her head at his receding back when
he'd returned to his office and
scribbled a few notes about the session
he found that he was too elated to sit
still and paced around his desk like a
caged animal twisting his hands in front
of him today had really been the start
of something big he could feel it
at last he might have some solid
evidence to back up his theory and if he
could get enough data together to
publish by the spring he chuckled to
himself dr. Emerson's book wouldn't be
out until midsummer at the very earliest
he wanted to beat the old bastard to the
punch still Restless Jenner began pacing
before his book shelves scanning the
titles even though he could have recited
them from memory zombie nature
understanding the reanimated exploring
the undead mind knowing he was torturing
himself a little he pulled a copy of
Emerson's first book off the shelf it
was called the cannibal conundrum and
Jenner sneered down at its cover without
being aware he was doing it it had
always I rotated him that his rival that
crotchety ancient representative of the
old guard had beaten him to publication
on a subject that was so central to his
own field of research namely when and
why had zombies the undead but generally
docile slaves familiar on Haitian
plantations morphed into the
cannibalistic monsters of the modern day
dr. Emerson had taken a strictly
naturalistic route in his well-received
book he'd argued that the lust for human
flesh was simply a genetic mutation of
the rare but potent virus that triggered
zombification after death the book was
persuasive Jenner had to admit that but
he was convinced that there was more to
the story
the zombies as he pointed out in his
short critique of the book didn't have
to eat human flesh to survive the fact
that so many of them were housed in
clinics where they were fed nothing but
vegetables and large doses of cannibal
inhibiting pharmaceuticals proved that
much the inmates of the numerous zombie
clinics around the country while no
one's candidates for inclusion in the
human family we're certainly as healthy
as zombies were ever likely to be so if
it wasn't a need was it a choice an
addiction a tradition carried in the
collective zombie consciousness that was
what Jenner was aiming to find out
he realized that his colleagues thought
he was wasting his time they all
believed that Jenner's theory relied too
much on zombie intelligence which most
everyone in the field agreed did not
really exist to anywhere near a human
standard Emerson had even ridiculed
Jenner's notions to his face at a
conference a few months ago they're
nothing but electric meat jack he'd said
pouring a third cocktail into the black
hole of his condescending smugness
they're like animals worse than animals
there's no thinking process going on at
all they don't mate they don't feel
compassion for others that they're kind
they just kill and eat Jenner had wanted
to deck the bastard right there and then
but he was able to control himself if
just barely revenge would come later he
knew when he published the definitive
work on the change as it was termed in
scientific circles his work would be so
brilliant that he would be entirely
vindicated and no one would possibly be
able to refute his ideas Daisy would
help him in his endeavors she might even
aid him in communicating with others of
her undead kind and who would be
laughing then smiling he slid Emerson's
book back onto the Shelf he couldn't
wait to get back to the clinic
the next day Jenner didn't even bother
with any of the other patients he went
directly to Daisy she looked as though
she hadn't moved an inch since yesterday
and it was likely she hadn't the
reanimated didn't need sleep or exercise
and it wasn't as though they had any
hobbies to entertain themselves the
nurses kept televisions blaring and all
the inmates rooms but Jenner had never
observed any of them paying the
slightest bit of attention hello Daisy
he sat across from her at the table in
the corner the door to her room was open
as it always was and Jenner could hear
nurses talking and laughing in the halls
and below that the shuffling footsteps
at the heavily medicated undead Daisy
drooled and swayed but she was
undoubtedly looking at him how are you
today she didn't reply of course her
eyes burned red a symptom of the
zombification Jenner found himself
wondering what she had been like when
she'd still been alive it was hard to
tell now what with her chalk-white
pallor flaking skin and underlying decay
stench but he supposed it was possible
that she might have been beautiful yes
he could imagine it if he looked hard
enough for another little while he plied
her with questions the same ones he'd
asked her yesterday the same ones he'd
been asking all of them fruitlessly in
the two months since he'd started this
research he wanted to know how she felt
what she thought about why she felt
compelled to eat human flesh she seemed
to be listening but after a while Jenner
began to get the distinct impression
that she was taunting him with her
silence I know you could talk if he
wanted to he told her conspiratorial a
leaning and closed again so close that
the rotting smell nearly gagged him
despite it being covered up with various
powders and creams I promise I won't
tell anyone
Daisy drooled and swayed Jenner sat back
and studied her she almost seemed to
want to talk to him he knew he could
break down her resolve given enough time
that was the problem though the damn
clinic only allowed him to visit two
hours a day so any progress he might
make usually had to be begun from
scratch on the following afternoon he
needed to observe Daisy 24/7 watch her
habits and see if she let something slip
when she didn't know he was looking and
he needed to study her natural behavior
which meant weaning her off the
medication he tapped his chin with one
finger noting that Daisy's eyes clearly
followed the movement could he get her
out somehow he turned and glanced over
his shoulder as though he thought aloud
in a way he couldn't believe he was even
considering such a scheme and yet her
eyes were blazing now as if she could
read his mind
Jenner stared back at her
would it really be that difficult take
her out for a short spin in the
courtyard and then wander ever so
casually off the path it wasn't as
though anyone would care or mourn her
disappearance the reanimated were
practically Untouchables creatures one
tried not to mention or even think about
especially if they were among one's
family members there would be no one to
miss daisy'
of course the act of liberating a zombie
from a clinic or of deliberately denying
them their inhibiting drugs was a fairly
serious offense but Jenner was after
bigger game a complete understanding of
the zombie mind and motivation and for
that he supposed a little law breaking
was more or less justified the doctor
chuckled to himself sure he was only
blue skying he'd never really had the
nerve to pull it off he'd get caught and
disgraced and his career might very well
be irreparably damaged still it would
make his research so much easier and
more complete having a subject so near
to hand Daisy made a noise then a sort
of snuffling grunt and Jenner nearly
jumped out of his chair it was the first
sound he'd ever heard her make and it
caused his skin to prickle as much with
unease as excitement are you still here
for a second Jenner the somme B had
actually spoken his heart leapt into his
throat and he realized it was only Vera
standing in the doorway behind him
visiting hours were over 20 minutes ago
and it's time for Miss Daisy's shot he
heard the nurses shoes squeaking as she
crossed the floor then she emerged in
his peripheral vision a large hypodermic
clasped in one hand Jenner got to his
feet sorry Vera I was just leaving good
thing too when Miss Daisy doesn't get
her injection she gets a little Vera
smiled and chomped her teeth together
repeatedly peckish indeed Jenner gave
the zombie one last glance as he left
her room she was still staring at him
her red eyes flashing like twin signals
of warning
when Jenna arrived at the clinic the
next day he pulled his car into the
closest space the one that butted right
up to the sidewalk off the courtyard the
space happened to be empty and he parked
there without really thinking about why
he had done it he had a horrible morning
ever sent it stopped by his office
ostensibly to borrow a monograph on the
zombie cortex but Jenner got the idea
that the old coot really wanted to screw
around with him a bit get in a few
choice words about his research Jenner
tried to remain professional tried to
maintain his tight little smile in the
face of Emerson's subtle digs but the
effort made his head pound by the time
the older scientist had finally left
Jenner's temples were throbbing so hard
that he could barely see now at the
clinic he sat in his car for a few
minutes
realizing at last where he had parked
and what his motive might have been for
doing so he could still hear Emerson
snide comments reverberating through his
brain providing a rhythm for his still
blinding headache having any luck
talking to the dead the old man had
chuckled strolling around Jenner's
office as though he owned the place you
become quite the laughingstock at the
Hilldale clinic the nurses think you're
crazier than the patient's he'd said it
lightly as if he were joking but there
were Barb's beneath the words Jenner had
turned to look out the office window so
that Emerson wouldn't see the Scarlet
flush in his cheeks I'm making quite
good progress with one woman there he
tried to keep his voice calm and level
oh and has she spilled all the darkest
secrets of zombie dumb into your waiting
ears Jenner could hear the smirk in his
rivals tone she understands what I'm
saying Jenner shot back biting down on
the next phrase which is more than I
could ever say for you he was irritated
by his own petulance but Emerson could
always push his buttons he didn't
mention the fact that Daisy had never
actually spoken a word My dear dr.
Jenner the old man said and Jenner had a
sudden vision of slapping the
condescending look clean off his face
the reanimated see us in the same way
that we humans would see a particularly
appetizing brisket they cannot help what
they are but that is all that they are
he sighed signifying that the
conversation at hand now officially
bored him and should be brought to an
end as quickly as possible anyway thanks
for the monograph I'll return it
directly and don't get too attached to
the flesh eaters will you old boy I'm
telling
as a friend Jenner had heard the door of
his office closed behind him and had to
work to stifle a scream of rage then he
shook his head back in the present back
in his car at the clinic that he'd
parked in such a transparently
convenient spot the Sun streaming
through the windshield seemed suddenly
to bright and too warm he opened the
door and unfolded himself from the seat
grunting as he straightened his back and
smooth his gray suit jacket then putting
all other thoughts aside he marched
toward the clinic doors Jenner waved to
veera trying to look casual nonchalant
even though his mouth was too dry to
speak after swallowing a few times he
tried again save Vera you don't mind if
I take Daisy outside for a bit do you
change of scenery and all that the nurse
shouldn't find anything suspicious he
reasoned after all didn't all the nurses
take the patients outside for walks
sometimes but Vera's still seemed to
give him a very fleeting look there than
gone before he could identify it
certainly doctor she said smiling
tightly just stay in the courtyard and
don't keep her too long you can count on
me Jenner coughed into his fist his
tongue like sandpaper
he felt he should say something more but
he couldn't think of a blessed thing so
he waved weakly at Vera then turned and
headed for Daisy's room fifteen minutes
later he was pulling out of the parking
lot with the zombie strapped into the
seat beside him he couldn't believe how
easy it had been how it seemed that luck
was going his way or could it be that
the clinic employees had seen him but
deliberately looked the other way
secretly glad to have one less drooling
subhuman to deal with it didn't matter
he supposed in the end he had made it he
turned left and started up the road
wanting to stomp on the gas and put as
many miles between himself and the
clinic as possible but he held back not
wanting to attract unnecessary attention
his palms were slick on the steering
wheel
he glanced at Daisy in the passenger
seat wondering if she understood that
she was free it didn't seem likely she
was simply staring out the window and
swaying the way she usually done at the
clinic Jenner couldn't help but feel a
little disappointed that she wasn't
expressing at least a minimal amount of
excitement at her new surroundings he
concentrated on the road ahead he
couldn't take her home that much was
certain the authorities would be on him
in hours and the scandal would ruin his
career and not much more time than that
Emerson in particular would get a big
hearty laugh about the whole thing
so instead Jenner drove a few miles on
the highway finally stopping at a
vaguely dingy roadside motel with no
sign and only one or two cars in the lot
he left Daisy in the cars he went into
the front desk and checked in under the
name Wade Davis then key in hand he
pulled the car in front of the room and
hustled the zombie inside under cover of
the falling dusk for the first hour too
Daisy was just as docile as she'd been
at the clinic but then little by little
the medication began to wear off she
seemed to become Restless getting up
from her chair and wandering aimlessly
around the room stopping occasionally to
stare at the poorly done landscape
painting on the wall or at the
meaningless images flickering across the
television screen Jenner had been trying
to talk to her since they'd arrived but
it was clear she wasn't paying attention
he was getting increasingly frustrated
shouting questions at her and then
cursing himself hoping the people in the
other rooms wouldn't hear him and
complain about the noise he was
beginning to think that her supposedly
alert days at the hospital was simply a
product of his imagination or perhaps a
symptom of the drugs he slumped back on
the bed gripping at his temples as
though he could preemptively dislodge
the headache that was beginning to take
up residence there Jenner dozed off
without realizing it all the stress and
set back to the past few days finally
catching up to him he was dreaming about
a dog he'd had when he was a boy a husky
puppy that used to lick heartily at his
hands and feet when he opened his eyes
he was still so immersed in the memory a
delighted laugh playing about his lips
that for a moment his brain didn't
register what it was seeing when it
finally did he leaped back against the
wall drawing his bare feet under his
body in a single motion
his toes had been in her mouth and she'd
been chewing on them he stared at her
horrified in return she just gazed
stupidly but was there a flicker of rage
in her eyes at being denied a meal he
couldn't be sure no he yelled still
keeping all his limbs clutched tight to
his body even though she had made no
further move toward him no not me he
sounded as though he was castigating a
toddler and he felt ridiculous but he
had to make her understand part of his
anger was derived from the fact that he
thought she did understand and was
simply being disobedient Daisy's head
tilted to one side the harsh neon glow
from the bathroom light was not kind to
her flaky countenance giving it a
ghoulish green tinge the medication had
fully worn off now though she still
didn't move Jenner thought he heard a
growl a rattling purr emanating for the
back of her throat she crouched at the
end of the bed she definitely looked
angry now and hungry
[ __ ] Jenner rarely swore but the
occasion seemed to merit the slip what
was he going to do with her trying to
talk her out of eating him might not be
the most effective strategy he suppose
he could go to the grocery store buy
some raw steaks or something see if she
would eat those instead which even he
realized was unlikely but he didn't want
to leave her alone in the motel room
what if someone came what if she got out
he swore again chastising himself for
his woeful lack of planning he thought
he'd been so smart thought he'd be the
one to break through the zombie
reticence and actually understand these
creatures even be able to communicate
with them to yes even to talk them out
of eating human flesh had he really
thought he'd be able to do that with a
laugh he realized that he had pictured
something like that another curse
escaped his lips this one for his folly
he'd have to get her out of here take
her somewhere that she could feed
without attracting attention he still
held out hope that he'd be able to break
her for cannibalistic habits but for now
he'd have to humor her
maybe when she wasn't so hungry she'd be
more reasonable so where could he take
her on some level he couldn't believe
that he was actually contemplating
setting Daisy loose on some unsuspecting
person out there but what choice did he
have
Leonard Chou down on him and hope that
she didn't eat enough to cause him to
bleed to death he had started this whole
fiasco by busting her out of the clinic
so now he'd have to see it through to
the end Jenner carefully climbed down
from the bed never taking his eyes off
her
the zombies gaze followed every move he
made the growling in her throat much
louder now sounding like a boat motor in
the tiny room Jenner saw her moved
toward him one tentative step then two
more he put up his hands to ward her off
thinking as he did so that his fingers
might look like tender pork sausages to
her the thought was horrible but
strangely amusing I'm going to take you
to get some food okay he said speaking
very slowly and clearly
do you understand he couldn't tell if
she did but she must somehow she'd been
human once for Christ's sake no eat me
get it he pointed to himself and shook
his head no at the same time I take you
to food here he pointed at the door okay
her expression didn't change but she
didn't come any closer either so Jenner
counted himself successful watching her
for any sign of movement he began to
walk across the room taking small
non-threatening steps heading for the
dresser where he dropped his keys he had
to pass within a foot of her and his
heart hammered expecting an ambush he
had no doubt he could take her she was a
slight woman and hopefully weakened by
hunger and medications nevertheless he
didn't relish the idea of having a chunk
of his arm bitten off Samba fication
wasn't contagious but the bites were
nasty painful and full of bacteria
amputation was the usual solution Daisy
did faint toward him as though teasing
as he passed and he had to use all his
willpower to avoid screaming like a
little girl
it wouldn't do to startle her not when
he thought he basically had her under
control Jenner grabbed his keys from the
dresser and then whipped around to make
sure she wasn't sneaking up on him
she had crept a bit closer the growling
still low in her throat but she seemed
almost curious as though eager to eat
him but wanting to see what he was up to
first it took him nearly 45 minutes to
lure her out of the hotel room and into
the car his stomach in knots the entire
time night had fallen outside and cars
rushed past on the highway though the
parking lot of the motel was now
thankfully empty jenner had a
heart-stopping moment as he leaned into
the back seat snapping the seat belt
tight across Daisy's lap and wrists
which he had secured with a bedsheet in
the second it took to secure the belt
her stinking mouth had closed over the
flesh of his right shoulder and the
prick of her teeth was like the sting of
a razor on cold dry skin he gasped and
pulled away slapping her heart on her
half rotted cheek before he realized
what he was doing in the aftermath with
the sound of the slap still echoing in
the dimmed parking lot Jenner thought
she looked more human than ever the
expression on her face exactly matching
the indignant rage of a living woman who
had just been slapped by a British man
Jenner was sorry he had done it but when
she lunged at him he slapped her again
then shoved her back against the seat
and slammed the door on her before her
chomping teeth could find any purchase
then he watched her struggling and
spitting silently behind the window
glass wondering if anyone had seen him
and was at this very moment calling him
a filthy wife beater
at last he made his way around the car
and slid into the driver's seat
Daisy growled and strained against her
bonds but she was on the passenger side
and couldn't quite reach him after a
while she must have realized this for
she quieted down and settled back
against the seat but Jenner could still
see her pulsing red eyes hating him in
the rearview mirror where to take her he
wondered as he merged onto the highway
his first thought had been to find a
bunch of homeless men under a bridge
somewhere and let her loose among them
perhaps they'd be too mercifully drunk
to know what was happening
thinking about the plan now he was
nearly paralyzed by a feeling of immense
sadness and self-disgust why just look
at him a well-regarded anthropologist
and author and all-around good guy
plotting the deaths of innocent human
beings and for what he couldn't keep
feeding her forever and the idea that
she could somehow be cured of her lust
for human flesh was now beginning to
seem faintly absurd in his day
all of this because he'd simply wanted
to know why why did the reanimated
suddenly develop a taste for human flesh
and why should he be punished like this
for wanting to find out he smacked the
steering wheel did it really matter why
the point was that they did maybe dr.
Emerson had been right all along and
then Jenner had an idea the parking lot
at the University was nearly empty and
he had no trouble finding a space mere
steps from his office before he did
anything he flipped open his cell phone
and dialed waiting for someone to pick
up when the call was answered on the
third ring Jenna rung off without
speaking and stuck the phone back in his
pocket Daisy had been fairly subdued for
most of the ride over but now that they
had stopped she perked up again wiggling
against the seatbelt and gnashing her
teeth together Jenner was almost afraid
to touch her but in the end he leaned in
quickly undoing the belt they're leaving
the sheet tied around her wrist and
pulling her out of the car before she
could start gnawing at him he walked
behind her pushing her ahead holding her
hands firmly behind her back the halls
were dim and deserted though he saw
slivers of light emanating from beneath
a door here and there other professors
working late he bypassed his own locked
office with barely a glance
Daisy seemed to be sniffing the air a
strange / rattling from her lips but she
behaved herself otherwise she seemed to
understand their purpose here Jenner
felt his confidence in his theory
returning after this perhaps he would be
able to work with Daisy more make her
case study the centerpiece of his next
book he would call it how I tamed a
zombie a new approach to dealing with
the undead it had a nice ring he had to
admit light shone through the pebbled
glass window of Emerson's office and
Jenner thought he could just make out a
stooped dark silhouette within he
imagined Emerson sitting in there his
pompous quaffed head bent over his desk
was he working on his new book right now
thinking about how it would crush
Jenner's ridiculous theory once and for
all
Jenner felt his jaw tighten along with
his grip on Daisy's arms she made a
funny little Yelp like a dog whose tail
has been stepped on Jenner saw the
silhouette in the office glanced up at
the sound
he'd expected the door to be locked but
it wasn't he pushed Daisy to one side
keeping a tight grip on her then simply
swung open the door and stood on the
threshold for a moment relishing the
look of surprise on Emerson's wrinkled
face clearly the man could see something
in his rivals eyes desperation perhaps
madness whatever he saw it obviously
frightened him and Jenner had to smile
at that Emerson stared at him obviously
trying to save face by puffing himself
up to appear intimidating after what
seemed like an age he spoke too loudly
you might knock Jenner especially at
this time of night he said what is the
meaning of this general most giggled but
then got a hold of himself maybe he was
going mad after all I've come to discuss
my theory further with you dr. Emerson
got to his feet his finger stretching
toward the phone on his desk I'm calling
security Jenner you're either drunk or
insane and frankly I don't have the time
or the inclination to determine which it
is he still hadn't seen Daisy that much
was apparent he was nervous but not that
nervous
don't call just yet Emerson Jenner took
a few steps into the room pulling the
zombie behind him her flesh upsettingly
squishy in his hand his body still
mostly concealed her I've been working
on a definitive proof of my hypothesis
doctor and I thought you might like to
see it for yourself
Emerson's eyes went as big as
basketballs and he backed away from his
desk the phone momentarily forgotten
Jenner I know that is not what I think
it is he was pointing to Daisy what have
you done for Christ's sake
I've only done it to show you to show
everybody Jenner answered guiding Daisy
entirely into the office and closing the
door gently behind her proof of my
theory big as life Emerson Daisy here
has been with me for several hours not
only that but her medication has long
worn off but you see she has not
attacked me yes she wanted to I admit
that but I have been able to dissuade
her she has self-control Emerson and
understanding however rudimentary Jenner
didn't mention that Daisy had almost
chewed his toes off or that she had sunk
her teeth into his shoulder in the car
he figured these were simply lapses in
her reason lashing out of the behavior
her condition had encouraged in her
and as such she didn't feel the need to
share these trivial lapses with his
longtime rival Emerson stood with his
back against the wall as though he'd
like nothing better than to disappear
into it his terrified gaze never left
daisies pallid face
call her off Jenner he said his voice
barely a croak
then is there realizing what he had just
said he relented all right I'll grant
that you have some control over her that
may be your ideas have some merit okay
I'll give you anything you want say
whatever you want just please Jenner
please call her off Jenner gave the
Zambian encouraging little shove in
Emerson's direction she was growling
again I'm afraid I can't do that Jenner
said his tone tinged with mock regret I
appreciate your recognition of my
breakthrough don't get me wrong and she
does have self-control I'm going to work
more on it in the coming months wean her
off the flesh-eating idea but at the
moment he sighed shaking his head at the
moment she's starving hasn't had a good
meal and I don't know how long you'll be
kind of the Last Supper for her before
she goes on the wagon so to speak Jenner
was delighted at his own analogy and
laughed long and hard
Emerson's eyes cut from left to right
looking for some escape but his office
was small windowless and cluttered and
Jenner was blocking the only exit he
closed his eyes then no doubt trying to
erase the reality before him you won't
get away with this Jenner he whispered
everyone will know what happened they'll
immediately suspect you Daisy was almost
on top of him now her shambling steps
growing ever more eager I'm willing to
take that chance said Jenner and then
the zombie lurched toward Emerson her
hunger and desperation giving her
strength she bested the feeble old man
easily wrestling him to the ground and
climbing atop his chest her eyes
glinting like Christmas bulbs Emerson
screamed once a soft papery shriek but
the sound was cut off only to be
replaced by a wet ripping noise like the
squelch of a hand and thick jelly Jenner
had thought he'd be sickened by the
sight of Emerson being devoured but now
that he was witnessing it he found
himself feeling detached as though he
was simply observing a lab rat run a
maze
Daisie eight and eight seeming to never
get full her teeth worried at the old
man's flesh tearing it loose and large
red gobbets she was soon a wash and gore
presumably so lost in her own orgiastic
feeding frenzy that she noticed neither
the flying blood nor the animalistic
grunts that issued from her body at
regular intervals it occurred to Jenner
that the sound might attract a security
guard but like the sight of Emerson's
flayed body the possibility seemed
unimportant when Daisy had eaten her
fill leaving nothing of Emerson but
tooth marked bones and a few bits that
looked like coughed up hamburger she
leaned back on her haunches closing her
eyes in a shudderingly human expression
of say Tia T Jenner approached her still
cautious but not really afraid of her
despite the mess she'd made of Emerson
she seemed not to notice Jenner at all
caught up in whatever past her reverie
and the minds of the undead Daisy Jenner
didn't wish to diminish the moment for
her but he wasn't particularly
interested in being seen here either
they'd been in the office a long time
and someone was bound to come around
sooner or later she turned her head at
the sound of her name and regarded him
with her now open eyes which glowed red
her than ever her gaunt ghastly face was
painted with blood her cracked lip
studded with scraps of skin and brain
those lips parted then exposing the
black moth mouth within and as Jenner
stared incredulous the growl in the back
of her throat came forward to form a
single word more she said for a second
Jenner was too stunned to react
how could she talk yes he'd believed her
capable of it to a point but now that he
was actually hearing it how could it be
none of the zombies he'd studied had
ever spoken and as far as he knew no one
else had ever heard them say anything
was their reticence simply another
function of the drugs they were kept on
as all of this race through Jenner's
mind Daisy had crawled a few feet toward
him seeming bigger now and certainly
moving faster after her meal it was only
then that the impact of her single word
penetrated Jenner's consciousness with
the force of a sledgehammer Daisy no he
said trying to sound authoritative but
only succeeding and sounding like a
terrified six-year-old good girl Daisy I
gave you a Mersenne now you can't just
he backed toward the door but she was on
her feet in milliseconds racing toward
him with unbelievable speed her former
shambling pace completely gone Jenner
felt the doorknob poking into his back
and his hand closed over it but she was
already on him fast and strong her
tongue churning over her teeth Jenner
struggled against her managing to turn
the knob in his panic and then he was
surprised as the door gave way dumping
him backwards out into the hall
Daisy riding his chest like a succubus
her claw-like fingers digging into his
arms he screamed flat on his back
wondering where in the hell of that
security guard was now that he really
needed him the man must be deaf for
Christ's sake
but Daisy loomed over him hungry and
red-eyed and feeling no pity seeing his
death imminent above him Jenner's
fevered brain went into survival mode
throwing up any strategy that might
conceivably save his neck Daisy had
spoken hadn't she and she had displayed
simple understanding and self-control
just as he pointed out to the old man
perhaps there was more of the human in
her than anyone realized
and what was human could generally be
reasoned with Daisy please Jenner's
voice was Reedy and desperate I'm your
friend right I helped you I took you
away from that awful hospital I brought
you here to get food why are you doing
this for a moment she seemed to be
considering his question though her eyes
still flickered and her bloody teeth
still gnashed
she was so close that he could smell the
sweet rotten stench of Emerson's flesh
on her breath she stared at him why she
said as though tasting the word sensing
he'd made an impression Jenner jumped at
the opening yes yes Daisy why she looked
hard at him for another full minute her
weight and sudden strength pinning him
to the floor then her shoulders rose and
fell almost imperceptibly and what
appeared to be an all to human gesture a
shrug of indifference I'm sorry doctor
she said in her grave dirt raspy voice
it's what we do she lunged forward mouth
stretched wide and Jenner had no time to
scream again
[Applause]
the factory loomed gray and massive
through the windshield it's three floors
studded with broken windows that
regarded the surroundings with flat
malevolence the sky behind the building
seemed only too happy to contribute to
the gloomy ambience it was only 2:00 in
the afternoon
but rain had been threatening since
morning Kirsten Osgood pulled her rental
car into the rubble-strewn lot and
killed the engine there were a few cars
already there though not as many as she
expected she turned to the boy in the
passenger seat should I park around back
he grinned nah nobody ever drives out
here except for us come on
his name was Micah and he bore the lanky
form and effortless Grace of someone
just on the cusp of majority he got out
of the car and closed the door behind
him
Kirsten was slow to follow reaching into
the back seat for the bag that contained
her notebooks cellphone and other
equipment she got out and stood near the
car digging in the bag for her camera
which she used to squeeze off a few
quick shots of the lowering structure
before them and it's background of
scudding purple clouds the boy had
walked some distance ahead and his
shadowed figure was a stark focal point
in the foreground come on dr. Osgood he
called she told him to call her Kirsten
but she let it go slinging the bag
across her shoulder she began to pick
her way through the sand piles and
mountains of shattered concrete slipping
a few times and cursing the lack of
traction on her slick black dress flats
ordinarily she would have worn hiking
boots on an expedition into the field as
it were but Myka had been very specific
about the dress-code
coming your funeral best he'd snickered
on the phone where would she'd want to
be buried in
he had waited for her about halfway
between the car and the abandoned
factories entrance and when she caught
up to him they began to walk together
Micah himself was clad in a somber evany
suit two sizes too big for him Kirsten
gasps he must have raided his father's
closet the solemn garb seemed
incongruous in juxtaposition with
Micah's rosy young face and the
whimsical fall of white blonde
dreadlocks that danced around his ears
and shoulders do you feel what you're
doing is dangerous Micah
Kirsten thought she felt a drop of rain
on her arm and she glanced up at the
rumbling sky Micah thrust his hands into
the pockets of his baggy trousers
dangerous nah not at all I've done it
loads of times more than anyone else
here it's not dangerous it's
transcendent man you'll see he grinned
again so widely that the pink of his
gums showed the entrance to the building
had been partially concealed behind a
towering stack of warped two-by-fours
and rusty machine parts just to be safe
Micah said with a wink
he led Kirsten around the rubble kicking
a few bits and pieces out of the way the
door itself was metal its surface
scarred with dents mica wrapped three
times paused then wrapped twice a squeal
of metal on metal sounded from within
and then there was another sound like
the pattering of rust flakes upon a bare
concrete floor the door creaked open
seemingly by itself Micah a motion to
Kirsten and she followed him inside the
dimness outdoors meant that her eyes
needed little time to adjust and within
seconds she was gazing up and around at
the vast ruined Hulk its contours only
partly visible in the gray glow from the
smashed windows it used to be a glass
factory ironically enough mica said as
though he had read her thoughts his boys
seemed to come from nowhere and
everywhere me and Krista's found it last
year is Christus his real name she asked
Micah shrugged it is now
suddenly a shadow separated itself from
the dark masses in the corners and began
to move toward them Hurston flinched but
then she saw that it was just an old man
perhaps the person who had opened the
door for them is this a scientist he was
dressed don't lean a long white sheet
that he had wrapped around himself
several times like a cocoon or a shroud
Kirsten thought I'm dr. Osgood the
anthropologist she said stepping forward
and offering her hand but please call me
Kirsten this close to him she could see
that his white hair was matted in filthy
his eyes wild he didn't move to shake
her hand and after a few awkward seconds
she withdrew it the old man looked at
Myka you're late the feast was supposed
to start 15 minutes ago he chewed at his
lips perhaps to demonstrate to Myka how
hungry he was sorry Isaac just lead the
way we'll be right behind you
Isaac turned his back it began shuffling
toward another metal door that gleamed
from the shadows beneath the rusting
catwalk Kirsten leaned close to Myka his
dreadlocks tickling her nose I get the
feeling I'm not welcome here she said a
few of the members don't like the idea
of outsider studying them mica admitted
but Christus is the boss and he said it
was okay everyone will come around
you'll see Kirsten certainly hoped she
would the rain had begun in earnest now
and fat drops beat a steady rhythm on
the roof leaking in through the cracks
and crumbling plaster the whole building
smelled of mold and dust and oil with
the fresher sense of chalk and candle
wax adding spice to the stew Isaac had
disappeared through the second door and
mica followed a few steps behind
watch your step he said glancing over
his shoulder Kirsten found herself
emerging into a space even bigger than
the first but much darker as the fewer
windows were high up near the ceiling
and appeared to have been painted over
the floor level was awash in the thick
yellow glow from countless flickering
candles alternating black and white wax
pillars that defined a gigantic circle
around the rim
in the center of the circle was a long
table covered with a black cloth figures
moved around it
their numbers unclear in the shadows
Myka spoke in her ear the feast he
explained gesturing toward the table
kind of a symbolic Last Supper
Kirsten wasn't quite sure what she
expected given what she'd heard about
these people but when a space cleared
she was surprised to see only an
ordinary table piled with ordinary food
of every description a whole roasted
turkey a couple of hams nuts in wooden
bowls boiled eggs various pastas and
salads and dips in white plastic
containers
she even recognized a few sandwich
platters and dessert trays from one of
the chain supermarkets in town she
almost laughed but managed to stifle it
none of the people in the room who all
wore black suits like Micah's or loose
shrouds like Isaac's save for two or
three girls present who wore simple knee
length black dresses similar to Kirsten
Zone seemed to have noticed her at all
so intent were they on filling the
styrofoam plates they held in their pale
hands well help yourself Micah said
placing his hand lightly on her elbow
and guiding her toward the table eat as
much as you want we always bring plenty
Kirsten wasn't particularly hungry but
she thought it best in the interest of
research and camaraderie that she go
along with all the customs in order to
get the entire experience she picked up
a plate from the pile at the tables edge
feeling like an intruder so you're going
to study us one of the girls stood at
her shoulder black eyes pierced by
reflected points of candle flame that's
sort of the idea Kirsten said
nonchalantly grabbing a handful of
pretzels I'm iliza the girl said she was
red-haired and voluptuous her skin like
porcelain Kirsten would you mind if I
ask you some questions after she wasn't
sure how they referred to the main part
of their ceremony so she let the request
dangle after the rebirth the flicker of
the candles made shadows across her face
turning her features into those of a
skull are you going to rebirth with us
Kirsten tried to smile I'm planning to
yes her throat was dry the smell of wax
coating the insides of her mouth and
nose
oh just wait Eliza said she plucked a
large piece of ham from the table and
popped it into her mouth hole afterwards
you can ask me whatever you want she
said chewing thanks Kirsten said the
girls stared at her for a few more
seconds then wandered off the black
fabric of her dress soon
indistinguishable from the garb of the
others
Kirsten finished filling her plate and
retreated to a dim corner trying to be
unobtrusive she didn't want anyone to
act any differently than they normally
would she simply wanted to observe them
not make them feel that they had to
perform for her she knew some
self-consciousness among the subjects
was to be expected but she preferred to
keep it to a minimum a few of the others
came up to her and introduce themselves
and since all seemed friendly and open
enough she was able to secure promises
for several more interviews her stomach
was fluttering uncontrollably a feeble
protest against what she had gotten
herself into but she still managed to
force down most of the food on her plate
once everyone had finished eating and
deposited the trash in a large bin near
the back of the room there was a general
milling around as members talked and
immediately with one another their eyes
lit orange and yellow by the flames
Kirsten couldn't hear what they were
saying but the air around them vibrated
with excitement and perhaps even a
twinge of fear although that might have
been Kirsten projecting her own state of
mind onto others the rain outside
provided a droning backdrop for the
musical cadence of mingle conversation
at some predetermined point that
everyone seemed to instinctively
acknowledge the voices grew muted and
finally stopped altogether
the people in the room at least three
dozen of them by Karstens rough estimate
began gathering silently on the inside
perimeter of the candle ring leaving a
large empty space in the middle Kirsten
spotted Mica's blonde dreadlocks in the
crowd and when she met his gaze he
beckoned to her smiling encouragingly
her heart was beginning to pound but she
returned his smile and moved toward him
situating herself between him and Eliza
in the circle
a man emerged from the ring and stepped
slowly into the center the candles
sending his shadow flitting off in
several directions at once the man
presumably Christus held his hands out
unnecessarily for silence and then
closed his eyes and began to chant in
some language Kirsten couldn't identify
he was a handsome young man about the
same age as Micah with close cropped
brown hair and a strong jaw his dark
suit bore a rather dapper pattern of
gray pin stripes which Kirsten found
strangely out of place given the setting
he wore thin rimmed spectacles and the
flames made the glass over his eyes glow
like twin yellow Suns once he had
finished his invocation he produced a
small object from his pocket Kirsten can
tell what it was at first but then he
knelt down and began drying on the
concrete floor with it and she realized
it was a long piece of white chalk there
was no sound in the room at all except
for the rain outside and the scraping
noise of the chalk is it defined shape
after shape in the center of the circle
Krista's worked quickly and confidently
his arms moving with sharp sure strokes
in the dimness Kirsten squinted to see
what Christa's was drawing it seemed to
be a series of large identical shapes
mirroring the arc of the circle like
long boxes lined up around a clock face
as he completed the top half of the
circle from Karstens perspective she
finally figured out what the shapes
resembled coffins she could have been
mistaken that was true but she didn't
think so the shapes were like six foot
long polygons short on top and longer at
the bottom where the legs would go and
now she could see by the flickering glow
of the candles the Christus had drawn a
neat cross in the middle of each box she
shivered
at last Krista's returned to the center
of the circle wiping the chalk dust from
the tips of his fingers he spoke again
in the strange tongue to Kerstin it
almost sounded like a nonsense language
with bits of bastardized latin and
perhaps french thrown into the mix she
glanced around at the others who all
stared intensely at their leader faces
beatific they clearly understood what he
was saying or at least pretended they
did
Christus then made a sweeping gesture
with his hand making the candles around
him gutter slightly in the ensuing
breeze the followers in the circle began
to move almost as though hypnotized
Kerstin felt a poke in her ribs and
turned to see micah pointing to one of
the chalk coffins on the floor time to
go he whispered it'll be okay
he then lowered himself onto his knees
and lay full-out inside one of the chalk
outlines folding his arms across his
chest and closing his eyes
a tiny knowing smile remained on his
youthful face the others except for
Christus were following suit lying flat
upon the floor the star attractions of
their own funerals Kerstin was reminded
unpleasantly of news footage she'd seen
about the mass suicides at Jonestown and
for a moment she considered simply
walking out going back to her office at
the University her book wouldn't be any
less thorough for not having included
this particularly bizarre modern cult
with it compared to some of the other
sects she was researching this one was
after all pretty small potatoes as she
stood there hesitantly the others had
settled into their positions motionless
as if death had already overtaken them
Christus was still standing in the
center his face partially shadowed by
the bright glow of the candles behind
him he looked at her kindly then
gestured toward the one remaining chalk
coffin at her feet the one that lay
empty waiting for her body to fill it
she felt the blood rushed to her face
then quickly dropped to the floor
arranging herself in a corpse-like pose
she didn't like the idea of closing her
eyes not knowing what to expect but she
did it reluctantly
in the darkness behind her eyelids all
her other senses became supernaturally
attuned and she thought she could hear
the steady breathing of all the others
in the room even here a few fluttering
heartbeats the smell of the candles was
thick in her nostrils making her sleepy
as she floated there hands trembling on
her chest she heard Krista's shuffling
footsteps moving away after a few
moments she began to relax wondering if
perhaps she might doze off before
finding out exactly what was about to
happen and it did seem as if several
hours had passed before Krista's
footfalls became loud again before his
breathing drowned out that of the others
playing dead beside her she felt his
presence very close and almost opened
her eyes but instead closed them tighter
willing him to pass her by there was a
sound very close to her face like a
quick exhale and then that was the
feeling of warm air on her cheeks and
something else a tickling sensation on
her skin like the brush of many tiny
wings it was pleasant at first and she
almost smiled but immediately it began
to hurt contracting the delicate flesh
of her face as though sucking out all
the moisture its stung and burrowed and
she gasped but she found that she
couldn't get any air at all then her
nose and mouth seemed to have ceased
functioning that the muscles in her
throat were no longer adequate to draw
oxygen into her lungs she panicked and
her eyes popped open but all she saw was
the fading glow of the candle flames as
they were snuffed out one by one she
couldn't scream or even shed a tear her
limbs were rigid her muscles useless her
eyes closed to their own volition and
she could not open them again the
blackness spiral toward her and overtook
her hurtling her into a nothing space
where she felt detached from her body
only her sense of hearing and smell
keeping her tethered to temporal reality
with her still working ears she heard
her heart slow its beating and finally
cease altogether and then an enormous
silence
it was impossible for her to tell how
long she remained in this limbo state
neither truly dead nor truly alive
neither asleep nor awake she could no
longer hear anything safer the
disjointed babbling of her own thoughts
it was a horrifying experience trapped
in a body that was no longer her own
unable to see surrounded by dozens of
the quasi dead each trapped inside his
or her own private hell her thoughts
began to twist and mutate in ways she
didn't like ways that could only be
described as madness after a while her
brain no longer produced words at all
but only a thin high scream that seemed
to ring in her ears from without it was
only after an infinity after she had
finally settled into her death and
accepted it that she was startled by
another blast of warm air upon her face
another tingle of falling fairy dust the
heavy footsteps were back again the
curstyn was so far gone that she could
barely remember whose they were or what
was happening to her the powder tickled
her nose and lips giving the sensation
of a limb regaining its circulation and
after a few minutes she found she was
able to open her mouth and wrinkled her
nose and a few minutes after that she
took a huge whooping breath that seemed
to inflate her lungs almost to bursting
it was painful but the tears that pumped
into her eyes were tears of relief not
agony all around her the others were
shifting and moaning and gasping a few
cried a few laughed with lunatic trills
Kirsten could see light spilling in from
the next room and the haphazardly
painted windows high above and she
deduced that it was morning they had
been dead all night watched over by
Christus resurrected by him when Dawn
came to face life anew it had been an
unpleasant experience but Kirsten had to
admit she could see the allure in it
once the followers had shaken off the
effects of the drug in its antidote
they got slowly to their feet and stood
very still in the middle of their chalk
coffins their heads lowered as if in
prayer
Kirsten followed suit trying to see out
of the corner of her eye wondering what
the next step would be but there was
only Christus in his odd pinstripe suit
going around the circle and lighting the
candles once again then stopping at each
follower to kiss his or her forehead and
draw a shape presumably across in the
same spot with a wave of his hand he
released the resurrect DS from their
Deathly prisons and then each follower
leapt gleefully from his or her chalk
outline face glowing with possibility
there was another banquet laid out on
the long table this one less substantial
but more suited to the morning hours
free bagels cheese's coffee and tea
person was impressed obviously a great
deal of thought and expense had gone
into the preparations she glanced around
the room for Myka but didn't see him
right away
she knew eliza and a few of the others
had agreed to talk with her but at the
moment she wanted to speak to Christus
she found him slightly apart from the
others not eating or drinking anything
but simply watching the followers as
they've asked in their rebirth he smiled
at her as she approached but it was a
distant smile that didn't touch his eyes
did you enjoy the experience he asked I
don't know if enjoy is the right word
but it was certainly enlightening she
leaned against the wall next to him
looking out over the candlelit feast how
long have you been doing this about a
year we only had five members when we
started out including Myka and myself it
seems an amalgam of belief systems she
observed Krista shrugged the core of the
doctrine of course is the idea of
resurrection we use many of the
trappings of Christianity because that's
the mythology that our followers are
most familiar with and because
resurrection plays a large part in that
mythology but the main inspiration for
the sect was Haitian Vodun or more
specifically the zombie powder used by
vote and priests described by Wade Davis
in the Serpent and the rainbow Kirsten
said yes Mike I saw the movie and
wondered if we could replicate the
formula
Christa's smiled indulgently as if
speaking of a beloved but not except
only bright child he's not one for
reading but he loves all the zombie
films Romero full Chi even the newer
remakes we incorporated a bit of that in
the belief system too we even took some
dialogue from movies and put it in our
invocations disguised a little of course
personally I liked the idea of a ritual
based around a symbolic death and
rebirth
so I began researching I stumbled across
the recipe for the zombie powder online
as it happens and it wasn't terribly
hard to make although obtaining the
Blowfish poison was a bit iffy the
antidote though I had to devise myself
cursed and turned to him and credulous
you mean you had to come up with
something to counteract the neurotoxin
Christus lowered his eyes humbly I've
always had a knack for chemistry nothing
more if anyone deserves praise it's mica
Kirsten drew in her breath he was your
guinea pig naturally it was all his
doing though I couldn't talk him out of
it Kirsten finally saw my cos blonde
dreads bobbing in the crowd and she
looked at him with renewed interest
it wasn't respect for him she felt not
really but neither was it pity or
disgust she wasn't sure what it was
exactly he could have died she said at
last
indeed he very well could have despite
his young age Krista's voice for the
stilted refined tones of an Oxford Don
Kirsten was impressed by his eloquence
but as you can see he seems to have
emerged unscathed as have you dr. Osgood
he smiled again more warmly this time
and drifted away from her to join his
born-again followers around the
breakfast table later Kirsten sat in her
office poring over the notes and photos
and recordings she'd made about her
experiences she'd managed to get four
different followers to answer her
questions but they had all said more or
less the same thing the sect had changed
their lives bolstered their spirits
indulged their need for ritual and if
truth be told
theatrical morbidity Kirsten hated to
admit it but she'd felt a similar sense
of renewed purpose since leaving the
compound this morning a sense that she
had cheated death and can now take on
the world without fear the feeling
lasted well into the evening she had
worked past her usual time not noticing
the office growing dimmer and dimmer as
the light faded outside
she only looked up at the sound of her
stomach rumbling she hadn't eaten since
the awakening this morning looking
longingly at her notes she finally
resigned herself to going home maybe
stopping for a quick bite to eat along
the way she rose from her chair her
muscles creaking and reached for her
raincoat the phone shrilled stopping her
hand in midair dr. Osgood
she said into the receiver so are you
coming again
The Voice was immediately recognizable
as Micah's Kirsten laughed so soon I've
hardly recovered from last night but she
want to write she paused did she the
symbolic death of the night before
hadn't exactly been a pleasurable
experience but there was something about
coming just to the brink of madness then
being pulled back that was exhausting
invigorating I suppose I wouldn't mind
one more go she said she thought she had
enough material for the chapter she was
writing but it wouldn't hurt to clarify
a few things now that she knew what to
expect we'll be meeting again tomorrow
night mica said his tone conspiratorial
do you remember where it is or do you
need me to ride with you I can find it
mica she chuckled a little at his
enthusiasm but frankly it disturbed her
a little he sounded like a junkie
hankering for a fix
same time yep see you there he had hung
up before she had a chance to say
goodbye
Kirsten put the phone thoughtfully back
into its cradle she had been researching
this book for nearly a year now and this
was the first time that she had actually
felt some kind of pull toward the sex
that she was observing she knew it
wasn't right wasn't objective but then
again what was one more time through the
motions no one was forcing her to go
along with the rituals she could leave
whenever she wanted to if she got
uncomfortable these people were not her
life and after the book was written she
need never have to see them again
so thinking she glanced once more at the
pile of papers on her desk then shrugged
into a raincoat and headed out of the
office locking the door behind her
it was sunny this time as she pulled
into the mostly empty dirt lot in front
of the compound but that fact didn't
make the building itself seem any less
menacing the broken windows glare down
at her like cataract ridden eyes and the
silence boomed like an authoritative
voice and her knocked the same shroud
clad old man Isaac she remembered pulled
open the metal door and admitted her not
speaking at all and barely looking at
her except to raise his upper lip in an
obvious gesture of contempt she followed
him silently through the echoing spaces
until they arrived at the room with the
candles which she'd already come to
think of as the chapel all the followers
were already there preparing for their
umpteenth Last Supper gathering around
the table with plates in hand
Kirsten spotted mica in the crowd and
waved to him he returned the wave but
the motion seemed listless and his
previously rosy complexion appeared
chalky and drawn Kirsten attributed this
to the pale flicker book illumination
from the candles and grabbed a plate of
her own from that point the ritual
strayed not at all from the one she had
witnessed two nights before this time
she was far surer of herself going
through the motions without hesitation
even lying down in her ersatz coffin
without so much as a qualms she found
that she even welcomed the fluttering
feel of the blowfish poison upon her
face and the tightening of the flesh
that it caused when she became immobile
she simply let herself float
experiencing the simulated death in a
way she'd been too frightened to before
the madness when it came was almost like
a warm nurturing embrace a reminder to
let oneself go to simply be at one with
the darkness and the terror this time
the experience seemed all too short and
she felt she had only just begun to
enjoy herself
when Krista sees light footstep signaled
the coming of the dawn the antidote felt
like an angel's wings upon her skin and
she breathed it in along with the
promise of renewal it brought the others
awoke at their own pace stretching and
yawning in their coffins smiling and
blinking their eyes conversation was
still disjointed at this point but
became more vigorous as the antidote
took its full effect
Kirsten bounded up feeling better than
she had in a long while the smell of
coffee and apple Danish
is making her mouth water as soon as
Christmas is blessing released her she
was heading for the feast table ravenous
then a thin screams stopped her in her
tracks
she almost knew what she was going to
see before she turned around as she did
the scene before her took on the
dimensions of a nightmare the flickering
candles making huge monstrous shadows
upon the walls the faces of the
followers sallow and long their mouths
and eyes as black as bottomless holes
most of them were gathered around a
particular spot on the floor where
Kirsten remembered mica bedding down for
the evening feeling as though her whole
body had once again become rigid and
lifeless
she began slowly moving toward the
gathering Michel a still is a wax
figurine his hands still crossed over
his chest his feet oddly bare beneath
the two long pant legs of his oversized
black suit his face was slack but
peaceful a hint of his sunny grin still
apparent Kristin stood at Micah's head
his hand open and his followers
questioning glances he looked up sweat
beating on his brow I gave him the
antidote Christus said his outstretched
palm was still coated with a brownish
powder he's dead
Eliza breathed looking down at Micah
with something like rapture he's dead
for real no Kirsten wasn't sure why she
had spoken wasn't sure why she was
suddenly the expert in such matters no
he can't be dead maybe the powder is
just taking longer than usual to work
maybe you didn't give him enough
she had knelt near Micah's feet and now
glanced up at Christus is twitching face
I did I gave him the same amount I
always give everyone his poem was still
open and now obviously trembling what
are we going to do we need to get him to
a hospital Kirsten said no that was
Isaac do you have any idea what they'll
do to the rest of us if they find out
about this we'll be arrested for
poisoning him there were murmurs of
assent from the others Kirsten looked
around at them well you can't just leave
him like this
perhaps he will come around in time said
Christus who was now standing a little
way behind the others his arms folded
across his chest
he looked calm but Kirsten could see
uncertainty
in his eyes we should just wait to see
what happens
Kirsten turned on him your antidote must
not be completely effective it is
Chris's his skin was waxy in the candle
light it's always worked before not this
time
she glanced down at my cos prone body so
young almost monstrously pale there was
no way he was ever getting up again and
then something he said on the first day
she had come here resonated in her ears
he said he'd done this more times than
anybody Kirsten said almost in a whisper
that's true
Christus was looking at her warily well
that must be it the antidote is only
effective up to a point
maybe after so much exposure it becomes
toxic or no longer does what you
designed it to do
Christus didn't answer the candles
flickered silently around him giving him
a faint orange halo Kirsten looked to
the others not Issac he clearly didn't
like her but Eliza and some of the
others she interviewed on the first day
please she said we can't just leave him
here he has a family she was met with
nothing but stone faces all right then
she whipped around on her heel and began
marching toward the exit but before
she'd even moved ten yards she could see
the followers closing in ahead of her
blocking her path don't do this she said
but they were doing it pressing their
bodies against hers they didn't seem as
though they wanted to hurt her but they
looked Stern and Kirsten had no doubt
that they could resort to violence if
she tried to fight her way through them
she sighed and raised her hands in
surrender fine I won't go and tell
anyone at least not yet what do you
propose we do in the meantime for the
moment we will sit in wait Christus said
morning opened into afternoon and then
began to fade toward early evening mica
had not moved an inch and in fact had
started to reek in the smoke clogged
atmosphere
he was definitely gone for good Kirsten
noticed the followers giving each other
furtive confused glances and she
surmised that they were also coming to
grips with the inevitable fact of the
death but we're trying to deny it to
themselves
she didn't worry about them at this
point they would have to come around and
face reality eventually just as dark was
beginning to fall outside the windows
Krista's stirred from the shadowed
corner where he'd been sitting he
crossed the room ignoring everyone's
eyes upon him and knelt down next to
Micah's peaceful corpse
Kirsten thought she saw his lips moving
but she couldn't hear the words after a
moment he stood up and surveyed the
assembled crowd Joshua
David Michael I need some help moving
him three young men separated themselves
from the gaping followers and approached
their master
Kirsten got to her feet what are you
going to do
Christus didn't even deign to look at
her bury him of course nothing more can
be done for him now she risked a few
steps toward them keeping an eye on the
others who seemed tense but kept still
for the moment you can't do that there
are laws realizing that appealing to his
sense of justice was probably not going
to be effective she changed tacks if you
bury him out here it really will look
like murder no one will understand
Isaac was suddenly at her elbow his
wheezing breath hot upon her skin you're
just a visitor here he rasped poking at
her with one bony finger you can't tell
Krista's what to do I can tell him when
something he's doing is wrong don't you
see that I'm thinking of the rest of you
of trying to keep you out of trouble
we don't need your help thank you said
Christus coldly he turned to his three
henchmen grabbed Mike his legs and arms
we can bury him out back near the shell
Mound
Kirstin opened her mouth to speak again
but she knew it would be useless there
was obviously no reasoning with Christus
or any of his followers at this point it
was probably in her best interest to
simply abort the project and get out
while she still could
the followers seemed momentarily
distracted by the lifting of Micah's
body so Kerstin began shuffling very
slowly toward the door cutting her eyes
to the left and right as she went
it appeared that no one was going to
stop her just then there was a scream
and that sound did stop her sending a
finger of ice racing up her spine over
where Christus and the others were
carrying the body was chaos and she
could hardly see what was going on in
the dim light from the candles
The Scream came again a man scream but
still very high-pitched clearly
terrified at the end of the scream came
a series of babbling sounds that almost
resolved themselves into words
one of which Kerstin was sure was biting
the other followers were rushing around
now knocking over candlesticks sending
hot wax splattering in every direction
snuffing out the illumination in the
dark Kerstin could see a struggle and
though she tried to make her way toward
the exit she lost her bearings in the
newly fallen shadows all around her were
the sounds of grunts and shrieks and
heavy breathing Kerstin found her way to
a corner and curled up there her hands
protecting her head the scuffle seemed
to last for hours though in reality it
was probably no more than five minutes
when the sounds had died down to almost
nothing
Kerstin risked a peek through her
fingers someone perhaps Christus had
righted a few of the candles and lit
them again in their paltry glow Kerstin
thought she could see a few of the
followers lying on the concrete floor
very still all around them were rough
black masses like Rorschach inkblots
Kerstin first thought of the black
candles that had been kicked over in the
melee but the more she looked the more
the puddles seemed to have a reddish
cast not like wax but blood more candles
were lit and then Kerstin saw something
that for a moment her reeling brain was
too stunned to understand there was mica
standing amid the prom' figures four of
the more muscular followers holding his
arms restraining him
Mika's smooth baby young face was
smeared with more of the dark substance
his eyes were Hollow and wild his skin
blue Kirsten watched him awestruck and
noticed that his chest did not rise and
fall his eyes did not blink he was a
dead man animated by some chemical
cocktail coursing through his rotting
veins
Christus emerged from behind the undead
horror a white pillar candle gripped in
his hand his face was scraped raw on one
side his well-kept hair disheveled he
stared down at the dead members of his
church and his expression bore nothing
of regret or responsibility his breath
came in great gasps I told you it always
worked he said between breaths
addressing no one in particular
Mike his eyes glittered in the firelight
he surveyed the crowd his expressions
suggesting nothing but animal need
Kirsten watched him transfixed the
knowledge that she should leave now
while everyone was distracted was there
but it was a distant voice in her brain
hardly audible she sat and watched Eliza
was the first to go forward
approaching Maiko with her hands
outstretched stepping over the bodies of
her dead comrades as if they were
nothing but strewn refuse Kirsten
couldn't see her face but her posture
was one of supplication adoration mica
said the girl her hands now only inches
from his face
you are the new Messiah she held her
fingers out toward his mouth and with
almost casual ferocity Myka leaned
forward and bit them off crunching the
bones between his teeth allowing the
blood to course down his chin
Eliza gasped at the pain but then
laughed a high gobbling sound take the
flesh of my body she cried and from all
around the room came a stirring the air
growing thick with it a feeling like the
one Kirsten had experienced at countless
religious revivals the feeling right
before someone began speaking in tongues
are rolling around on the floor like a
possessed thing
Eliza was practically cramming her hands
into Mica's mouth now and he was
obliging her tearing off the meat as
quickly as he could chew and swallow it
Kirsten leaped to her feet almost
without thinking her body longing for
escape but she found that she could
still not turn away from the spectacle
Krista's picked that moment to intervene
trying to pull Micah away by his hair
the four men that had been holding the
undead creature were loosening their
hold
perhaps drawn in by the drama unfolding
before them perhaps falling under the
spell that Eliza had woven by her
sacrifice Krista's strength was not
equal to Micah's and the leaders efforts
were mostly in vain
stop this he said waving the lit candle
and Micah's face hoping to deter him
Micah is nothing but a monster he's not
a messiah I'm your Messiah and you must
obey me
his voice echoed like a God's voice but
it seemed fewer and fewer of the
followers were heating it though isaac
staked out a position right behind
Christus and screamed dissent with his
master's wishes
Eliza had fallen to her knees clasping
her not offhand to her chest letting the
blood spray in great arcs around her her
eyes had rolled back into her head and
she was murmuring something under her
breath something that sounded like a
chant most of the other followers had
gathered around her touching her with
tenuous fingers as though she was a holy
relic and then they were forming a rough
line in front of Micah beseeching him to
make them holy as well by taking a
sacrifice of their body it was like a
communion in Reverse Kirsten finally
awakening somewhat from the disbelieving
thrall that had held her began to look
around the room for her bag hoping she
could get a few photos at this momentous
and bizarre occasion she began searching
along the walls for it finally seeing it
push back into a corner not far from
where she was standing the whole time
she could hear shouts and screams and
ecstatic moans punctuated by Krista's
ranting and the sound of teeth crushing
bone and sinew the waxy smell of the air
began to take on the pungent stench of
an abattoir
Kirstin had retrieved her camera and
focused the surreal scene in the
viewfinder when she noticed that the
dead church members on the floor were
also beginning to stir and with mounting
horror she watched them struggle to
their feet wounds gaping and blood
spilling as they moved Karstens fingers
froze on the shutter button Myka had
taken exploratory bites from several of
the church members by now and some were
lying on the concrete floor holding
their wounds and allowing themselves to
quietly bleed to death their faces aglow
with a strange in her light christmas
and isaac and a few remaining followers
still on the side of the living had been
backed into a far corner their faces
white and terrified as they saw the
growing numbers of the Church of the
Dead it was clearly going to be no
contest
Kirsten finally managed to squeeze off a
few pictures before cramming the camera
back into her bag and heading for the
exit no one had noticed her so far and
Booker no books she wasn't going to let
this continue any longer she would have
to get out to call the police or someone
who could come in here and stop all of
this whatever it was that was happening
in the guttering dimness she saw shapes
gathering ahead of her blocking her way
to the exit panicked she crouched down
and ran straight out them hoping to
force her way through by keeping her
body as far from their searching teeth
as possible the space near the door was
nearly all shadows and she shoved her
way ahead blindly lashing out with her
arms in her heavy equipment bag for a
moment she couldn't breathe feeling as
though the smell of the candles and the
blood was choking her and she tried to
scream but no sound came out just when
she thought she could see the door ahead
nothing more than a rectangular crack of
light floating in a black space she felt
hands clawing at her from all sides
fingers scraping across her back and
shoulders she did scream then but her
scream was lost him and the agonized
howling from Christus and his few
holdouts who had finally fallen to the
adherents of the new creed in the
stinking darkness Kirsten felt her bag
and her clothes being ripped away and
before the fingers and teeth began to
sink into her flesh she had time to
think of her forced conversion time to
think of whether she would remember
herself when she awakened as an acolyte
of this new denomination a schism of
monumental proportions she thought and
she had been here to witness it
then with gnashing teeth the followers
of the new faith descended